novena given just a few weeks after
presenting its new 5-series generation
reports our cards history Manoa BMW has
added another model a plug-in hybrid the
530 produces 185 kilowatts and can go 50
kilometers on its battery alone / to the
plugins top speed is 235 km/h but at
that speed of course you won't meet the
car makers stated fuel consumption of
1.9 liters per 100 kilometers
sudden honda Manawa says the electric
motor and the gasoline engine together
provide the same power as in the 530i
and so you get the same acceleration of
0 to 100 in 6.2 seconds and the battery
alone will move the car at 140
kilometers an hour except you won't get
very far after all 9.2 kilowatts isn't
that much from the outside the hybrid
looks hardly any different from its
conventionally powered brothers
[Music]
blue accents in the kidneys brand this
vehicle as a plugin
[Music]
and of course the models full name on
the rear also indicates that this is an
electric vehicle the interior has the
elegance and luxury that people expect
from BMW
[Music]
the 530 east battery can be charged via
a cable from a household power outlet or
a charging station but starting in 2018
a simpler method will be available
external cameras will guide the car to
park over an inductive plate for
wireless charging
[Music]
[Music]
current flows through the primary coil
in the plate on the ground a secondary
coil will be installed in the cars
underbody the primary coil produces a
magnetic field that inductively charges
the car's coil with up to 3.2 kilowatts
of electric energy this is the same
technology already in use with
smartphones and now being tested in
buses the BMW 530i is the sixth member
of the five series like the other models
all kinds of safety and assist systems
are potentially available and the 530 II
drives like the other cars in the series
while using less fuel the trade off the
trunk holds 410 liters quite a bit less
than the 530 liters the others provide
[Applause]
but they're here as Amano demonstrates
the battery is placed under the back
seats and you see the result when you
look in the trunk this is shown up and
is still looking to get rid of those
sacks of sand any mono will use them the
mono says the days are long gone when
people put ballast to the trunk to
provide more traction select Mathis the
battery and the regular engine are
accompanied by a standard 8-speed
steptronic transmission and rear wheel
drive the electric motor is located in
front of the transmission and uses its
gear ratios - this makes a torque
converter unnecessary which compensates
for much of the electric motors extra
weight
[Applause]
I listen Olivia manawa says the 5:30
cost between two and seven thousand
euros more than the 530i or Effie 520d
but it also has better fuel economy than
the gasoline only model and is faster
and quieter than the diesel and a purely
electric range of 50 kilometers is
nothing to sneeze at so the 5:30 is
definitely worth considering especially
for commuters who don't travel beyond
that radius and can charge their battery
at reasonable cost the basic price for
the BMW 530i in germany is just under
fifty four thousand euros
[Applause]